you know it's funny every single time
they mentioned this character's name
Mach oh I always want to say yeah I know
it's Mach oh it's it's very nice you
named a character after him but it's I
know that's how it's pronounced that I
know it's not Mako it's just a lot more
people are saying Mako and that's and
sir what I start doing I just kept doing
it's just you know I have enough people
yelling at me about pronunciations and
characters names and now the show is
doing it what the hell
so that's not what you I hear about you
I hear about episode 2 which is a leaf
in the wind and first of all that is
very cool that the name one of the
characters after Mok Oh Mako I'm just
gonna go back and forth I don't um but
I've heard it's it both ways so out I'd
say Mako for so long and you know the
actor uncle Mako this character oh come
on there you go um but uh okay so you
got we finally see what the opening of
the show is like and I think how they're
gonna talk about previous episodes to I
hope they keep that up it's sort of like
this old like thirty style film stressor
like the news last time on The Legend of
Korra we saw actually got in a fight and
blah blah blah
it's like I I really hope they keep
doing that cuz that's really funny and
again it helps give the show a little
bit more of a different identity than
the previous show so I like that I like
that it's again it's feeling very
comfortable in its world and it's sort
of embracing it and it's not feeling
like oh what we have to do this because
avatar didn't know it's doing something
else it's moving on while still also
being in this world while evolving the
world so I like that I think that's
really cool um they you got this thing
where Korra is trying to learn uh
airbending and she is just too
rambunctious and she doesn't have the
patience is trying to learn it but it's
just finding it very very difficult very
frustrating and finds out about this
thing this sort of bending tournament
that's going on it is sort of bending
fighting and goes over there meets these
two boys who are you know who are
competing doing really well fine
she's avatar and then of course one of
the guys didn't come through Oh what are
we gonna do let's throw her in there
you know the shtick uh and of course
just at the point where she's becoming
so frustrated with airbending that she
says I think this is the way I want to
go so kind of seen the story before but
I think what really helps it out what
saves it in my opinion it's not bad
episode but again your serve going and
seeing it seeing it but what really
saves it in my opinion is eight that she
uses the techniques that she did learn
from the airbending master a black ass
name again I could of try it but um that
she learned from him uh in the fight and
I like that and it it worked very
naturally you know she has to dodge and
you see what that's for and you see
they're all really shocked that they
can't get her and I like that she learns
that hey the brute force isn't always
the way to do it but it comes out right
point because she's just seeing
everything else she's trying is not
working so it's sort of this okay well
try this and that works so I like that
it felt very fluent that felt very just
very very flowing who I mean um I did
just feel very natural to go into that
and I liked the fact that both her and
the teacher uh acknowledged their faults
cuz again I think a lot of shows would
really drag this out and would just have
it where he doesn't like her for a bitch
she doesn't like him they'll they'll
carry over for about two three episodes
or something like that least and then
they come to this understanding oh maybe
I've been kind of a jerk and they come
to it at the very end and I I like that
they both acknowledge that they've
screwed up and I like the fact they
acknowledge the teacher his sort of been
screwing up - he has not been keeping
his patience as well and that matches
the character that seems to be a guy who
means well but it sort of takes what he
does very seriously and is not used to
having people really talk back to him I
mean it's just it's obviously holds us
to a great art and doesn't have a
phenomenal sense of humor about it but
it's not harsh or mean either so it's a
makes sense that she would sort of walk
all over him and he would just you know
a problem or you know that sort do that
thing so uh so I really like that I felt
those are the two elements that pulled
this through okay and made a decent
episode um the you know I've heard
people talk this is like the one thing
I've heard about this show before going
in of course a lot and from what I heard
people cast let people either like hey
I'm glad they're doing something
different or others are like that's not
avatar it's not like I can just watch
avatar again
um but a lot of people are saying that
this Korra character is a little too
much of a hothead she's a little too
closed off and brutish and and so forth
um the reason I think so far I think it
works is because a when she makes a
mistake she comes around to it very
quickly and that's good so because there
were points here I'm just like oh come
on girl come how will you open your eyes
and say and she does and she doesn't no
way that sort of makes sense like I said
using the moves and seeing that it works
that was very effective that that does a
very smart way of doing it um but here's
the other thing I'm so realizing
especially in this one where she's
having a real hard time getting
airbending and I like that airbending
and not firebending because that would
be the easy route to go again they would
have had the opposites because that was
the hardest with Aang was like Earth
well that's the opposite of air well now
you have water opposite of that would be
fire and they do air I like that because
it's not necessarily the power it's the
attitude this time uh and the attitude
of the Water Tribe is not usually like
her she's a little different because you
have a blowhard and she the fall of
herself and such so I like that the
philosophies are what is not gelling
here and why it's so difficult for her
so I I think that's cool I like they
didn't go the obvious route with
firebending
um but why would I realize I enjoy about
this character and why I think this is a
good route to take with the character is
because when you see her during the
airbending
sessions you know with the meditating
and trying to be calm and trying to be
relaxed and her just not able to do it I
mean she's just so anxious angsty and so
rambunctious and wants to go do stuff
and wants to listen to the radio and
wants to get into the fight and wants to
talk about the end of blah blah blah
this sound like any generation or a
couple of generations you might be
familiar but it's us it's us and it's
the generation right after as the
Millennials or whatever they're called
um because and yeah you could always say
like oh that's any generation and
probably kids yeah but I think there is
something to the fact that the more
technologically advanced we get the more
stuff is made easier for us and because
of that sort of the more sheltered we
become and more spoiled and selfish and
now with that said there's many great
things that come from that do don't get
me wrong but at the same time there is
this great impatience because everything
is handed to us is set well there's
always something that entertain us now
that there's nowhere you can go where
there isn't something entertain you
there's ads everywhere there's computers
everywhere there's internet everywhere
if I get bored I'm a lesbo too if I get
bored waiting in line somewhere i phone
go online see what's going on track the
website I'm part of it too so I'm not
gonna act like oh you were now see kids
I'm totally in this as well uh you know
the social media and so on so forth so I
think this is actually a really good
reflection of a lot of people right now
especially a lot of younger people you
know our generation sort of grew up with
this being discovered the Internet I
mean there has really will change
everything uh but the generation address
the Millennials uh they're growing up
just with this in their world you know
so they've never known a time without
this and so much of that is losing this
sense of quiet and this sense of self
and in some respects the Internet can
help with a lot of self because
everything is about ourselves you know
it is a face
book and Twitter look what I did today I
did this I did that me me me me me which
in many respects is good you can
discover things about yourself you can
share things with yourself but there's
never that sense of being alone and
quiet and as much as we try to distract
ourselves and shove entertainment and
pictures and whatever in front of us
you're gonna have those moments where
all you're gonna have is yourself and
you can't you can't trick anyone but
your sight yeah oh no a person you had
to drink is yourself and why would you
want to trick yourself so if there's
that sense of just being comfortable
with yourself but I think it's very
obvious that core is not entirely
comfortable with herself she is
impatient and she is anxious and even
though she served talks and acts like a
blowhard she knows she hasn't hit that
area of failure yet that she really
needs to confront I'm sure she's gonna
have to confront so I like this
character because of that I think it's
actually a really good representation
Obiang folk today in our generation and
especially in a city that is so
technologically advanced now it seems
like they've made all these huge
improvements and now you have this this
teacher who obviously is a generation
that was you know raised by Aang the
Avatar who you know it was raised among
the monks and knows all about quiet and
peace is very playful and everything but
also is very very quiet and knows
himself and knows inner peace and so
forth but there wasn't as many
distractions there are distractions but
not as many and our distractions
nowadays are just made so accessible to
us and you can get them anywhere so I
like this I like this route that they're
taking cuz a lot of people I saw a lot
of people do like oh I'm so sorry you're
gonna watch Korra oh she's such a bomb
but I I don't know it works for me
because I see this going on with so many
people right now so many people that
just cannot get this idea of quiet and
silence and how important it is and how
as much as they try to run away from it
it will catch up with them and it's
important to be ready when
does or even welcome it instead of being
so frightened by it like so many people
are so yeah I enjoy scare endure for
that maybe reading too deep into it I
don't know but uh that's what I see you
know when I watch this character and
when I watched this world that's one of
the reasons I really like this is that
this were all so technologically
advanced and that it is almost like you
know serve a 40 style City uh so yeah I
like the direction that's going um it is
very different and I again maybe if the
one thing I do service from them its
ourself far as Episode two but the one
thing I the two things I miss from
Avatar one is the colors and I do sort
of Miss the the humor a little bit more
from Avatar which is so funny when I
should start off I was like yeah the
humors and I gets so good so um yeah
this seems like the story is a little
bit more relatable to kids but the
delivery of it is a little bit more
adult like I said not quite as many I
mean the most of the characters are
drawn as like adult they don't have the
huge gigantic guys like the little kids
do as you normally give kids big eyes
and drawings anyway so um I'm liking it
so far I'm curious to see where it's
gonna go
and yeah I'll just see where it goes
take care